[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
the quickstart tutorial
for Cloud Functions.
We're going to see how to deploy
a Cloud Function from a Google
Cloud project.
To start, make sure
you've got a Google Cloud
project with building enabled.
The first thing you want to do
is enable Cloud Functions API.
In the Navigation menu,
click on API and Services,
and click Enable
APIs and Services.
Here, search for Cloud Functions
and select it from the results.
On the Cloud Functions
API page, click Enable
to enable it on the project.
Next, head to Cloud Functions
on the Navigation menu.
We'll find this under
the Compute section.
Click here, where it
says Create Function.
Name your function
whatever you'd like.
For this demonstration,
we'll keep
HTTP selected as a trigger.
Keep Inline Editor selected
for the source code.
As we can see here,
Cloud Functions
support multiple runtimes.
For now, we'll use Node.js 8.
By default, we're provided
with a basic hello,
world function that will
respond to an HTTP request.
Click on the expanded
Editor window icon
to get a better look.
We won't have to make
any changes here, so
click OK to go back.
Here, where it says
Function to Execute,
is where we would specify the
function in our source code
that we'd like to execute.
In this case, hello, world
is the only one that we have,
and it's the one that
we want to execute.
Click Create to deploy
our Cloud Function.
The Cloud Functions
Overview page
will give us a general overview
of all of our Cloud Functions,
including region,
trigger, runtime,
and the time of its
last deployment,
as well as permissions.
Once it's done deploying,
click the menu of our function
and click Test Function.
On the testing page, we
can test our function
by sending a triggering
event in JSON format.
Our test function
responds to events
by outputting the
value for message,
so let's send it a JSON object
with a value for message.
Click on Test the Function
and check out the output.
As we expected, the
function outputs the message
that we provided above.
Down below, we'll see the log
associated with our function.
There are entries for when the
function execution started,
as well as when the
function finished,
along with status code.
We can get an expanded
view of the logs
by clicking here, where it says
See All Logs for This Function
Execution.
Here we'll see the same log
entries, along with a lot more
information should we need it.
And that's all there is to it.
We've successfully
deployed a Cloud Function.